so I decided in this documentary to do a
social experiment where I will move to
one of the poorest towns in the UK go
and live in someone's house who has
nothing no money at all and see if I can
teach them my knowledge and my skills
and see if I can make a poor person
become rich in one week let's see what
happens
welcome to the YouTube channel if you if
you don't know this guy he can't we did
a financial freedom challenge in
Blackpool
how many months ago it was 8 June last
year 2018
yeah no 19 oh yeah 19 so we're probably
I would say like 8 9 months so then we
did have a six-week with you yes which
was on the original documentary and you
you were honest a cruise boat somewhere
yeah yeah probably I was a rainy
Blackpool yeah yes exactly
now it's eight months on delighted to
have you on the channel we want to pick
your brain we want to know what's
happened since then you've been very
successful in deal sourcing you've got
some really cool stuff going on yeah
because before we met and before we did
the FF challenge you'd never had any
tenants I didn't have any property
experience didn't explode I'd read some
books I think like most people who read
the Kiyosaki's and all that kind of
stuff yeah I hated myself but not taking
any action and I think one of the
reasons people related to you so much
was because you were very much like
you're a very normal guy yeah in terms
of poor man a poor man cording to the
title you approve the title though so
yeah well I think I think it's a really
interesting point the whole the whole
title of it because I think poor man
financially yeah
but mentally I think the biggest thing
I've taken away from from this entire
process is is understanding myself much
more because it was I really felt like
for you to come into someone's house and
you are just a whirlwind when you're
there like whether the cameras are
rolling or not you're just on all the
time yeah and I think seeing you works
for that level made me realise how low
and little I was living my
from a professional level so I've
learned so much mentally you thought so
much since it's done a huge amount since
so why don't we just reach out in if
anyone's watching this who hasn't seen
the documentary yeah I would highly
recommend checking it out and it was
crazy I think it's had like four hundred
and fifty thousand views to shot half a
million views without saying you've been
bombarded with messages since yeah kind
of a bit of a celebrity almost yeah good
and bad good and totally fair I again
going back to the mentality think I
think a lot of there a lot of the
comments which kind of hurt my pride and
my ego at the time were like well you'll
never be successful I look at your poor
mind I think I think you have been
successful so to say oh yeah to to a
really great extent compared to what had
happened the years previous to it yeah
it was it was a case of because I had
doubt in myself my own ability I think a
lot of people looked at it as well
multi-millionaire property investor
comes to your house lives with you
showed you all the cards like you know
here's here's what you need to do his
illusion here's that you know here's how
it all works and I'm still there having
doubt I'm still there go know well I've
got doubt about it and I don't know if
it works to be fair some of those doubts
turned out being right because some of
the deals that were gained in that
documentary never actually turned out or
turn out to be problematic yeah but the
whole process of I suppose believing in
myself yeah I've actually going to Noah
it is possible I am good enough you know
surrounded by a lot of people who in
working-class England you know look at
it as you know you can't attain now
you're not good enough to attain that or
who do you think you are kind of thing a
lot of got a lot of stick like a lot of
people gave me a lot I hate I think when
you've got that many views a half
million views almost yeah you're always
gonna have some people that are gonna
say bad stuff yeah as well as good stuff
but I think that on the whole I think
the documentary despite a lot of people
I don't know I think it helped a lot of
people I think it definitely I don't
know I said leave it on the week by then
loads
I just just by being because because we
were starting again we were doing deals
Blackpool was absolutely brand-new to me
yeah I've actually never liked
blackboard as
that's my area I know that you know and
I told you that and that's one of the
reasons why I accepted the to do with
you because I just thought god no
property experience at all we didn't
know each other we'd met through the
eviction yeah
but haven't known each other very long
just for a few months black Paul
starting with absolutely no money yeah
this is gonna be a challenge and a
challenge it was so why don't you talk
us through them so on the week what
people saw was they saw that we got a no
money down lease option agreement yes we
had to pay for the contracts yeah which
we paid through deal sourcing correct we
got to renter rent deals yeah the
service accommodation yes in Blackpool
and we made eight thousand pounds Sasa
in sourcing money but most of that money
was used to pay for the down payment on
the lease option stuff because of course
we and one of the things really
important as well is if you're gonna do
lease option agreement to get drawn
properly yeah because that way if things
don't go well you need brake clauses in
there you need so we did that we did it
properly it was going well six weeks
after we touched base and you'd filled
the property the lease option property
up really well your tenants you're
correct me if I'm wrong by the way your
rental service accommodation deals fell
through but then you'd replace them and
you get some more and that's kind of
where we touched off so yeah I'm all
ears tell me what happened okay
the lease option agreement yes was
atrociously bad
in what sense well the reason was is a
couple of the tenants in the properties
were one was a mom's a drug addicts one
tried to kill herself like look I know
you say you don't live like Paul
Blackpool needs a majorly problematic in
certain areas yeah it's one of the most
and economically downtrodden places in
the UK from from my own experience and a
lot of the tenants who were looking for
HMOs especially in the location now I
can say oh yeah I had some property
experience because I'd read a couple of
books but I'd not been out on the
streets of Blackpool and seen what were
good areas what was what was a valuable
property where do people want to live
you kind of have ideas but we're talking
the different sides of the same street
can be the difference between Mayfair
and Old Kent Road yeah you know I mean
yeah there's a
SIB divides in terms of value and desire
of where place yet places that people
want to live this HMO wasn't in a good
area it's funny because the same road is
split by one main road one side which is
the same name of the street is great the
other side where our HMO was wasn't
great so we had that issue so police
were involved you know paramedic for it
was what I realized when people are say
oh you know you'll always be poor cause
your mindset and stuff I took on the
biggest most complex deal I mean you
know you go and do a crash course and
say go and buy a two-up two-down
buy-to-let house and rent out four five
hundred pound a month and you pay three
hundred pound on it yeah it's going to
run him up this is a four-bed hecho mo
lease option agrees it was it all that
it's got all that it's got everything he
takes everybody and I was I was trying
to run before I could walk and that's
not that's not your fault
that's like I was hungry for the
philosophy and idea behind it
when it came to actually doing it it was
tough yeah it was really hard so anyway
we flushed all those tenants out started
again we had more problems with people
who'd lost their jobs who couldn't pay
the rent it was it was infuriating and
it's only this week that we've managed
to fill the whole place it is now
official with good tears yeah well with
touchwood we'll have another one it will
have another chance yeah yeah yeah I've
been like those tenants were rubbish
these here's the thing who are the
tenants now that the tenants are all
nurses this is something I learned this
was like a key thing not less because
this is great this knowledge by the way
now this is experience on me yeah you
had promised new tenants which is awful
and probably the worst type of tenants
but I think they're learning from that
from people watching this now yeah it's
potentially awesome what is it what is
it you said bad tenants worse than it I
said bad - it's worse than no tone I
totally agree with that originally I
thought you were lying oh I like
everything I would have thought no
chance and the other tenant in that it
was funny there's if you go back through
the documentary there was a point where
you and I was sat in the car and you
said how are you feeling about
everything I said I'm slightly concerned
and I'm slightly overwhelmed for the
simple reason I realized I'm taking on
three four or five grand a month
outgoing yeah and you said oh isn't
that's never really been a thought
process yeah because you're thinking
about how much can I earn from it yeah
so because of that my my motivation soon
you went because then I'm like it's like
mama ducks you know gone off the cliff
and I'm like flappin can I can I survive
I don't fly yeah my first thought was
I've got to get this full because when
the term comes around and I've got to
pay a grand for the URLs in the rent and
all that kind of yeah yeah I can't lie I
mean I could because I had a buffer from
the deal source in but I couldn't be in
a situation where the first month with
this new landlord on a lease option for
oddness massive building yeah I think
that I failed on that so I filled it
with the wrong people
yeah you know and I learnt a major
lesson do you think that because because
you felt the wrong people do you think
that you were so desperate to fill it
fast I know again there's there's no
like saying oh you did it bad or you did
it wrong because it's just all in it
yeah you think that you were soaked
because you feel that so far I couldn't
always say I said to you after the
challenge I said look I think it's
probably realistically gonna be for six
weeks and then you phone me up there for
72 hours you phoned me up when you said
dude I felt the whole thing in 70 hours
and I've never been like that that's
almost weirdly fast yes do you think
it's because I was I was desperate yes
to your question I was desperate to get
anybody who would pay money yes it's
being one of those so what is the lesson
from that the lesson from that is first
of all get tenants if you do it hate
this is specifically for HMOs now if
you're if you're getting tenants for
HMOs make sure they all do a similar job
so for example out of the four rooms two
of them were nurses that will work in
nights yeah the other two were one was a
construction worker one was a binman
so one's out first thing in the morning
one's out in the afternoon the other two
are out at night but their their routine
of cooking and stuff it was all over the
place so I was getting phone calls I'd
be I basically became dad at one point
so it'd be I'd get a phone call going oh
someone's left some hair in the sink you
know someone's left you know someone's
left their pans on the side yeah it's
like you're all adults come on sorting
out and those little blips you know
problems in HMOs I found this twice now
there's little blips of Oh
someone's got a problem someone's got a
little issue with another tenant that
unchecked is like a weed in the garden
it just takes over faster than you could
possibly imagine
so you have to get announced your
question you have to get the right
tenants who live on a similar even same
job so so
now these tenants that are going in
there and this week of all nurses yes
they all work at the same place they all
understand each other's work cycle they
just have they're just on the same level
yeah as opposed to just get in I mean I
had issues with racism like I had all
sorts of stuff because of different
cultures different ages different
genders different different everything
and I think that it was really tough
that's a really good point as well
because sometimes people say to me
should I have students or professionals
in that DSS and it's like have one but
yeah stick with that I'll know you mark
it absolutely rather than trying to mix
and match so everything is way in terms
of management because when we spoke on
the week yeah I know we had a management
company and we spoke to management
companies in the area
yeah what are the pros and cons between
self managing HMO because you've
obviously looked at both and what the
president's business self managing and
getting a management company to deal
with it for you would you say because I
know your deals like when you're sending
it down deals cuz you're very successful
deal sources and really well on that sub
which we'll get to
yeah but when you're selling deals to
people all over the country do you
suggest they manage themself do they get
someone to manage it like how does that
work that is that is a loaded question
that needs to go down a few avenues so
take it away okay
so firstly I think you should only be
deal sourcing in areas that you know I'm
I'm the probably the biggest proponent
for deal sourcing being in one area so I
sauce exclusively in Blackpool I don't
do anywhere else and I never will and
people go well why could you know you
cut in your nose off to spite your face
you can't go worldwide when you just do
Blackpool and it's like I don't care
because I know Blackpool really well it
would be immoral that means a city with
you now and go I've got a seven bed HMO
in Scunthorpe that's great and you look
at the numbers of it like I know now
having gone through what I've gone
through that looking at numbers on a
piece of paper and on a spreadsheet is
the is the opposite end of the spectrum
actually being in there and working into
yourself so so if your package deals to
sell only sell deals that are in your
local area yeah I think deals there
needs to be good deals deals that gonna
make money yeah and and it's it's fair
to say you know what I'm only
comfortable sewing deals in an area that
I know really well ya know the deals I
mean I think
I think it would be immoral for I'm not
saying you I'm say the Royal you for you
to sit there and say and pull out an
email to your list saying I've got one
in Newcastle one in John O'Groats one in
Devon one in London and one in
Manchester because you don't know that
area and and I've learned this from
doing it for a decent period of time now
is that with regard to the HMO
management side of things I can't unless
it's in my area so I've got properties
all over the place no I've got HMOs in
Doncaster I've got properties in Leeds I
got a problem using Wales I've got
probably's all over so but I've got good
management systems in place sure so what
what's the craic with management because
you managed the properties yourself it
didn't go great yeah
what are you doing now are you managing
yourself still and no I've got I've got
another property manager the way I works
as I flipped that question on its head
which was yeah the the the revenue
generated when it was all full on paper
yeah all that revenue generated the
amount that it would make was about
eighteen hundred pound seventeen
eighteen hundred pounds yeah which was
which was huge real No
yeah but the profit was going to be
about seven 800 quid is it something
like your lease options yeah this isn't
this is on a lease option agree
depending on the bills and stuff it
could have potentially got to a Grandia
with management and stuff it's about
seven 800 quid yeah I was thinking to
myself with the stress that I was going
through would I pay someone all of that
profit to take this dress off my hands
mmm and the answer was yes because it
was really getting to me so I was like
okay well it's not worth me doing it
then so the pros and cons of management
pros and management obviously you don't
have to give away ten fifteen percent
it's fully in the game eight members but
you seem like already retired land your
ace I hate saying I want to say you
leave it dealing with what I love is
yeah looking at a property going this
can be turned into this or when this is
done this is gonna look like it's right
near the coast service accommodation you
know we can sell this deal long because
we don't know I love that I love the art
of the deal and I love the the financial
process and I love the left-brained
logical side of it dealing with tenants
like if someone else gets joy out o then
be my guest always your question I
you've been through a lot of problems of
tenants okay yeah are you glad because
my advice to you initially I was like
yeah and management
yeah yes but let me assure they were
terrible okay was that the one that
works eggs and it will make anyone yeah
yeah potentially terrible yeah are you
glad that you did that yourself I mean
you've got now hmm I know company which
hopefully a good and you've got tenants
and it's great but are you glad that you
went through that from a learning
experience or going back would you say
you know what I'm just gonna get a good
hack team and management or would you
not take on a property at all like what
what what as I was coming up on the
train today I looked in the mirror and
saw a big grey hair coming out of the
side of my head and I have no doubt in
my mind the landlord out was a landlord
hair that was like that bloody tenant
you know right into arrears or whatever
but going back look into one glad I'm
really glad I'm really really glad that
I went through the experience of what
happens if you don't do it properly like
you don't screen your tenants if you
jump in too fast free fear I'm not
having a place full yes yeah I'm really
really glad I know know as well that
like I mean you've been to the crash
course I spend quite a big segment
talking about how to reference tenants
and vet tenants or what does it do sleep
well I don't specifically remember that
do you know yeah because we do at the
crash course we spend our section on
tests maybe we could maybe we could
spend more time on that I don't know but
we spend we talk about vetting tenants
and getting reference get your previous
landlord credit checks we talk about
that do you think that there should be
more focus spent on that or do you think
the key is just get good management
company and don't don't be involved at
all what's the I forget the learning
good boy you can stack a deal well if
you look if you can look at a deal and
it like it's kind of laughable sometimes
if someone goes can you check for you
this deal and there is so much wrong
with it that the numbers are wildly out
yes if the numbers are totally correct
and what you say is true when it's in
the X area and whatever tenancies your
only issue in from my experience which
obviously isn't as long as a lot of
people yeah more tenancy getting the
right tenants in there like when you
used to say you know a button and is
worse than a good tenant what a waiver
no a bad friend is worse than no time
that yeah I literally cannot agree more
with you yeah because it because it
makes or breaks your business I mean
I say we I've consistently lost money on
that lease option agreement up until
literally this month
yeah because wrong tenants flushed him
out tried a different bad wrong tenants
flushed him out ice cost I'd say
probably maybe seven eight thousand quid
that's a lot
why don't you not because I know we
obviously we did it properly we had
solicitors to all the contracts are
weird bright clauses I think it was was
a three-month and I've did we tempted
after three months just go you know what
I'm gonna give give up give it up based
on the bright Claus and I was I was
emotionally tied to it and because it
was my first ever deal yeah cuz I'm your
firstborn you don't sell it down the
river yeah work hard because believed in
air because I mean I know you were there
but I felt like I found that deal I
found online I look today I'd yeah oh
you know I did it
yeah I'm to be honest like the deal and
obviously hindsight's a great thing and
matches it wasn't amazing was it not I
mean was it on paper fantastic but was
it great I don't know I mean you've got
the Cubs to appreciation from it
assuming that it goes Rivera which I
think it will a black hole is
unbelievable honestly it was this is so
diluted
yeah and dilated with regards to where
the market sorry it literally cannot go
lower and I say that you know you'll
probably come back to this in a year's
time and be like no no that's true but
there was a there's been some land boy
in Blackpool who's actually bought last
week for 300 million pounds yeah I think
Universal Studios or one you know
section of that company and they're
spending a huge amount of money in
central Blackpool and a lot of other
properties been you know started being
bought up around there and it was funny
because two three four years ago
Burnley was the hot place and was like
buying Burnley you can buy a house
before it grand 50 grand 60 grand
birnley's gone up you know you say
everywhere follows in London London went
up then Birmingham then Manchester then
Liverpool then Burnley eventually went
up black bull he's still stack yeah and
that's why that's why sourcing there is
such a and that's also why that's one of
the reasons why I really badly want it
and I was really glad that we did get a
lease option anyone that's watching this
is thinking what on earth y'all about so
the deal that we got was a lease option
meaning that you have
we fixed the price now what did we agree
to four hundred and forty thousand jeez
mate so we've agreed to buy four hundred
and forty yeah how much did he pay for
it he paid one hundred and fifteen for
it about twelve thirteen years ago he
did a massive refurb on it he did how
much did he spend I don't know how much
he says IFIF I don't I spent three and a
half okay on it so [ __ ]
fine so he bought it for 115 spent loads
of money on it you've bought it or got
the option to buy it for 140 yeah in how
many years
seven seven years so we know and also
crystal ball but we're assuming that
goes up in value after seven years
you've got the cabbage depreciation I
mean that's cool so younger though
you've paid you've been down because of
bad tenants mhm I would still if it was
me personally and everyone has different
stress holds and stuff going back six
months ago I would still sign that deal
I think I would say but if I have my
time again I'd be I'd be way more
professional is the word yeah I'd be way
more professional with the tenants and
here I got in there yeah I really would
because I because I know as soon as
those right tenants are in there which I
think now having gone through the
vetting process yeah I really feel like
it they're they're good people they're
all friends they're all nurses they're
all you know they seem conscientious and
all that kind of I feel like I just feel
a gut feeling that they're the right
ones that's good as soon as that happens
even if I mean there was a point in time
where I thought rather than have a
four-bed hecho moment at sea bed flat
have it as a full bed flat and a to bed
flat and it would still make it would
still make money you're still my prime
know I think you've bit you've been
through stress on it it's been have
you've been hard you've got a couple of
well-deserved great landlord hairs I
think as long as that hasn't broken you
and you've got to the point where you
just like app you just like I hate
property now yes long as your
appointment actually I've even on me
even down yet on that deal financially
mmm-hmm but you know what I'm glad did
it still got the deal you're gonna go up
I've now but are you making money when
those toes moved in or the song yeah no
though they've signed okay I love signs
okay they are paying 350 each per week
yep so the four of them and the
downstairs five 500 pound a month which
is only which is only just recently been
so
so that's dinner so as we stand today 90
about $990,000 management company which
you need i do you need i do once you've
paid the hmm manager and bills can you
pack everything how much profit between
seven and eight hundred quid
okay month which is which is good but
it's happy it's hands off and now that's
what I want now because deal sauces
become my main my main things it work
the guy has asked me and asked me into I
think trying to do this in TV for months
yeah you have to be fair I've been
pounding yet yeah to come down but
you've been saying I just want to come I
just want to come but it's sometimes
never the right time because the in
property it's a business there's always
gonna be good things going on the
business there's always been bad things
if you're white everything to just be
smooth and no problems if you've got a
lot of tenants a lot of investors loss
that's always gonna be good that's
always gonna be bad the question is
overall are you making money overall how
I think the reason I think the reason
why and I know you probably don't want
to hear this but I think the reason why
I put it off for the last couple of
months is because half of the people who
were commenting on the documentary
fantastic like Anthony Wilma actually
Redland guys on at like they helped me
with my with my health like I share
people know what's going on with the
health situation the other half were
were brutal to the point where I'd to
get the police involved
so people were posting stuff about my
kids my kids school my missus stuff like
all my bank did just everything and I
got I got to a point where they were
really coming for me and I I'm really
I'm just quiet
well yeah me too but I but I realized at
that moment that my association and I
think it's a hypocritical view from
their perspective because you know if
you look at that in a vacuum and say a
multi-millionaire is offering to come to
your house for seven days to teach you
how to become financially free and
property you're telling me they wouldn't
take it of course they would but I think
I'm like a low-hanging fruit and an easy
target and because of that because it
was a case of I I I was waking up every
day and it affected me psychologically
like I've never I've never been
depressed or anything like that but it
was it was every time I'd open face book
or every time I'd open my email it'd be
we know what you are like I had to get
the police involved it was it was really
brutal and I think because of that I was
like I need to step away from this
spotlight that certainly I've been
thrust into yeah and I thing is I didn't
expect it it was like coming out of the
back of it I thought I looked at it as a
learning experience people would gain a
lot of information about what it's like
kind of on the ground and all that kind
of stuff
yeah but you know what though that
obviously that's outrageous yeah you
only told me that last week yeah but
that's the read like it's not that I've
been avoiding you it's that I've been
I've had to calculate in my head doing
this because I know that when I get home
or when this goes live I'm gonna get
more people going oh you some yours
buddy again like I can't win either
either way whatever happens I saw why
because do you think in a way that the
property stress how was the property
stress compared to the having half a
million views on a viral video address
I've had that before like I've had
videos that about five six million views
but they're all football video so you
kind of expect Liverpool fans to
eight-man United fans and do you think
it's almost like the skeptics turn
something like oh like almost I mean in
Britain yeah there are in American
refuge if you're driving around a
Ferrari people say hey fantastic in
Britain if you're driving a Ferrari
people yeah try and bring you down yeah
thank you do you think that a lot of it
not and I mean we could analyze it all
day but and you say it's serious you've
got the police Iman stuff sounds
horrible but do you think some of that
online trolling that you had personally
and I get it as well but do you think
that it's because you went from being in
Blackpool yeah you're a nice guy and now
suddenly and I know we can talk about
deals awesome even very well making lots
of money do you think there might be in
like jealousy or do you think what what
why I think you know I think it would be
I think it would be immoral to not touch
on the obvious which is you had a lot of
heat at the time around you and I think
a lot of people came after me because of
because they wanted to get to you and I
was I was caught in the crossfire of
that and obviously you you had your PR
firms and you had you stuff like kind of
looking after you and yet I think you're
a stronger person
mentally I think you can deal with that
better I'm just like a family guy trying
to start a new career yeah and every
relationship I make with a new investor
or whatever is cut short and cut down
because somebody wants to cut me down to
get to you and I think that that was
that was difficult to deal with because
I'm like just just let me be I mean I
have people on my channel like I've when
it's Wednesdays yeah every single week
either are the witness winds down my
channel I have guests on the show yeah
but no one after anyone like they were
media I think I think because there's
one thing somebody sitting here and
going oh you know I'm buying buy selects
and my portfolio is now 10 million
pounds or whatever with me you came in
summer hat not you I mean the audience
came in summer house they experienced my
children make it like they were sat on
the couch with us you know things like
this I think there's more of an
emotional connection with it I think you
know like you say we can analyze this
all day and all I'm saying is it was a
really tough time and that's why I
wanted to get all my ducks in a row or
what - yes understand because it was
like being reborn this because I know
I've wanted to get into property but my
thought process was always oh you need
to have lots of money and you need to
have deposits and stuff and you came and
proved that you can do it it is possible
and yeah and you walked me through that
and I'll be forever grateful to you for
that all this color a rule that came
around it was somewhat damaging for a
period of time yeah but I got to a stage
where I was like well like screw you if
you want if you want to sit at a
keyboard and just throw shade at
everyone then fine whatever like I'm
building my you know I'm building my
business and we've gone from strength to
strength and you know done incredible
things in a [ __ ] place I mean I mean
respects you know fair play to you had a
lot of had about tenants being shown
stuff I had no idea - I don't think you
told you didn't definitely tell me about
the extent of the height of stuff which
is which is just ludicrous and yeah I
mean definitely next time I spoke to the
to my office and HR team was definitely
said never we do a viral video yeah we
need some kind of support emotionally
without doubt for if someone's going to
be getting because my channel I mean
geez my channel my youtube channel
started out with just me vlogging my
property journey now I'm getting over a
million views a month on the channel
yeah it's it's quite a big YouTube
channel yeah you know so but you did the
thing is it's not like like we we know
Simon Wilson mutually you know a YouTube
vlogger very successful from from
Blackpool actually lived in Blackpool
for a while he's he's not like selling a
product he's just him vlogging yeah
here's my journey here's I'm doing he's
not saying about Richie well exactly
well you're you're helping people today
financially to a great extent yeah and
also charge and I think is fair to say
like a significant amount of my you know
the money that you tried as a business
to be fair a lot of people have gone
through it I've had great returns from
there it's a significant amount of money
I think you've seen is I'm not saying
you saying the ROI as soon as you start
broadcasting that and charging and
people are making these huge amounts of
money is really easy to become a target
and at that and at that point emotional
when we when we did the thing
emotionally spiritually financially in
every level I wasn't in a good place
because of whatever my illness that I
had and suddenly all of these that
there's a war going on and I get and I
suddenly get caught in the middle so the
support really for anyone whether
they're in the Academy come to a crash
course like you do you breaking down a
lot of barriers with what you do which
is phenomenal like it is a it is a wrong
journey of that I don't think a lot of
people would be prepared to take to
stand there and try and help make
people's lives better by breaking down
common mental barriers that a lot of
people have a huge amount of people have
and put in such a massive spotlight on
on on me really in this in this you
exist in which no I did want because you
didn't saw that you didn't know exactly
how I was gonna planet no I didn't I
didn't expel our from it let's see
something else as well yeah obviously
you've had stress from tenants and from
that and from almost half a million
views on YouTube video what happens with
that what's been the flipside because I
know you deal sourcing businesses be
very successful how much of that do you
think be honest with me okay
is down to the good exposure that you've
had oh absolutely yeah all of the
positive yeah from deal source in has
come from the exposure from that
right so you so yeah you know you take
off with it it should never be that
rough and geez Ivana known yeah I'd have
been like friggin phoning you up saying
come around my house I really have come
on my house after I've had dinner
together yeah but you know but I think
the exposure that you've had because I
think branding and that's something you
understand yeah you know branding the
exposure that you had off the video I'm
glad to know at least it makes me feel
better cuz of some of the hate yeah yeah
knowing that your deal sourcing business
you know has been massively helped with
me a big part of the positive exposure
you've had from coming on the YouTube
channel there's no there's no doubt with
regards to the deal sourcing that people
dealing with me for a certain interim
period after that documentary went out
associated dealing with me from a
sourcing perspective with dealing with
you so so it is it is incredibly
positive because there's all like with
sourcing it's all about trust it's
almost not about can we get these extra
1% out of the deal of the yields or the
ROI is to trust you know I've got
clients now who have remortgaged their
house yeah and released equity that
they've said they've paid off for 30 40
years become awesome because you know
Blackpool Wow yeah you've stick into
blackboard and I'm so glad that the
people that you're selling deals to
because I know that a lot of them are my
people they know about you from the
video modular but I'm glad you're
looking after them you deals well to
them you've made you're making pretty
good money really well we've done we've
done two point just over 2.6 million
pounds of property sales that's not
revenue to our company that's how much
property we've sold since June last year
which is when we went together which is
before that had you ever sold a deal to
anybody never which is awesome it's
funny because one of these pea crew put
a thing up saying oh he's got no
property experience and they found a
post that had made from like 2017 or
something saying I
you know he's sold deals before when I
looked at it and I was like I think
right I drank up an estate agent Gaad um
hi yeah this visit there's a house you
do not I mean like really kind of
sheepishly I didn't see that I'd have
looked at the I've looked at the numbers
on it and I on my
I am so far out with regards to how much
rent it could get Hamill yeah and I
didn't know that no honestly the
sourcing has been it's been
life-changing I think I didn't I didn't
anticipate being a deal sorcerer what
what I loved about you being when you
came to Blackpool was those old habits
yeah we're kicking in if you can't do
this you're not good enough to do this
and and that was that was rampant I
still have little bits of it now and
then but that was absolutely rampant and
the fact that you said we need three
four grand to do these deals and I was
like I don't have three or four grand
you're like don't worry we'll get it
like we'll do it and the fact that you
unlock to that in my mind that that was
potential was was was just endless to me
and I built a good career off the back
of that and we're so phenomenally well I
think you're even like you've set up an
online an online course
you got so many questions from people
saying yeah it is yeah you know what
that's really interesting as well
because link is the description
yeah well put a link in the description
but it's really interesting because
people you know people will say to me
you know and I know you messaged me
before you did that and stuff it was it
to me is it is it bad that Glen's trying
to you know teach people effectively or
show people about deals yeah soon
because I teach people I do YouTube
videos but I've always said to you in
terms of you should continue document
your journey yeah show people because
might my philosophy is like I just want
to spread this message you know I want
to spread the message of financial
freedom
yeah of you don't have to work 40 hours
a week for 40 years to retire and 40% of
what you couldn't afford to live on in
the first place yeah there is another
way yes that is that going to come
hardships of course but so does working
until you're 67 sure is all so you know
if you want to be a property
entrepreneur you've got no money start
from scratch
is it going to be easy no it's simple
it's easy to do it very easy not to do
it it's gonna come with hardships oh
yeah but like for me I just want to
spread that message and that's why
anything that you've done like that I
will believe in a link in the
description because I want I want as
many people as possible to get the
message that's coming from me it's
coming from you if he's coming from some
of my other students you know then you
know I'm happy I think I think what it's
doing is it is it's filling a gap
because rather than go into one of your
events which are amazing because this
three days everyone's together in a row
that you've got live events now yeah
fair enough fair enough but you know you
got drive down there and you get the
hotel Union there for three days and
take three days off work the reason that
I created the deal sources Secrets is
because I got the same question same
five or six questions every single day
yes foot four months here's a manual
getting it today and in the end what I
was doing originally was going oh hi
John you know thanks for your message oh
no she's got two kids in your profile
picture how are they what are their
names and I'm but you know I go through
this whole process you don't see your
question about compliance yeah here's
what you do and done it and I was just
doing the same thing it wasn't a good
use of my time it's in the end I just
thought I'm gonna I sat there for about
three or four weeks and just said this
is everything I know based on what you
taught me what I'd learn after the
documentary and all really everything
that's gone on since then the 2.6
million that we've sold that's the first
question how much profit have you made
and this exact specific but from deal
sourcing after we met in June or from
when deal saw since ho all I couldn't
say exactly it so way over 50 grand
maybe 60 that's awesome yeah if I
remember when we met you know because I
said to you let's try and make six grand
this week yeah we just like I don't even
comprehend that call yeah yeah yeah I
can't even so the fact that now and I
did it in 15 minutes yeah you did eight
eight thousand and fifteen minutes it
was yeah one thing that I have and let's
be totally open and transparent about
this one privilege that I had about
doing this together is that when I sold
those deals
I wasn't legally compliant to do so yes
because I want I didn't know what
compliance was at that point and I
passed those deals through some Academy
members that you know yes
Anthony and Alastair helped me out so
Alice they honestly it's been a diamond
to me I bought in a little glass saying
like if with a Southern Comfort which he
likes and I was just like thank you so
much I you did have support like because
the thing is everybody was rooting for
you yeah and even that event that we had
that networking event I put that
networking event on know him yeah you're
gonna come yeah yourself and I know
yeah was it Alastair Antony they sold
deals to their investors yeah I didn't
even charge you a fee no they didn't
they gave it they gave you the full they
gave you the full fee but you didn't
need that forever because it was only a
matter of time what's the video went
viral yeah and now you're an independent
yeah compliant experience yeah deal
sorta say a little story yeah there's a
great building in Blackpool on white
gate Drive which is one of the main
arteries going into into blackboard mmm
and it used to be a Morrison's local
back in the day anyone who knows
Blackpool will will know this building
it's 4,000 square foot in the mercial
unit great location and in Blackpool
there's not many that lets to say most
of the pubs are all old men flat cap
with it at the bar you know pint of
Boddingtons you don't get much for the
kind of younger younger female or like
the younger couple wanting to go out and
have a good meal so the good thing we'd
deal saucing I never started out wanting
to be a deal sorcerer but I was viewing
loads of property you know and you say
you know go and have your big day where
you did like 10 12 whatever in a day I
was doing that every day I couldn't do
them all so I was I was passing the
month so ended off at this property and
I thought I'm not gonna buy a commercial
unit you know I can't turn it into HMO
or anything or anything like that and
that little voice in my head that you
talked about and Grant Cardone talks
about when we met him was like you know
you should do something with this right
you just you get a feeling don't you I
think you came to him with it and I
thought right ok and I was talking to
the to the vendor and she said this
would be a great restaurant it'd be a
great bar and restaurant that's like
actually yeah that little voice you
can't do this you couldn't open a bar or
restaurant so I'm like ok so I didn't
want to immerse words all out worked out
how the building was gonna work spoke to
the council I like put a lot of legwork
in and purely through my deal sauce in
list up to this point I've raised over
200,000 pounds in private funding just
from getting in touch with people and
selling the idea of this is what we can
do this is you know this is how great it
can be we're gonna do cocktails and
pizzas and all that kind of stuff the
reason I say that isn't so like you know
blow my own trumpet but is to illustrate
the fact that when you're confident
you're our property which you get
through education
yeah and you have a list of people who
believe in you you keep regular contacts
with them they trust you and they know
that you've got their best interest at
heart then they'll follow you yeah oh so
now trying to give people a piece of you
know anything that I'm doing not you're
big you are a big thinker and you are
I saw the print you sent me the video I
think was like the video you sent me
with the proposal for the rest ah yeah
that was no that was the one so I said I
created a video I was like I told you
that yeah I was like dude that's so I
mean yeah in creative also as well
because you've had lots of many crazy
things going on you've moved house yeah
thank you
am i right in saying you the house that
your new house is a lease option
agreement house come on dude spill the
beans right
my strategy yes as a as a property
investor and not as a deal sorcerer or a
serviced accommodation provider anything
I just try and see as many houses as
possible and I think you blinkie
yourself if you go into a property
thinking I just want this to be an HMO I
only do HMOs are you nothing else by
hate remotes you cut yourself off so
this this commercial building is an
example of that when you go in and go
this could be something and this house
that I saw looks fantastic great area I
know that now because I'm experienced in
that area
great area close to schools really close
to the hospital which is like the one of
the main areas in blackpool great
location so I went round had a look at
it and it was really beautiful but it
was it was old needed a lot of work
hadn't been loved in a long time they
didn't care it needed a family he needed
a good life in these walls so I thought
okay I could sell this and then I
thought actually because we were renting
at the time and we were renting for
twelve hundred and fifty pound ammonia
and if I remember right that was most a
lot the majority of your income at the
time a lot of because a lot of people
said oh you never did a pretty good
house but what they didn't realize is
that was most yeah income to be fair
that's the same people who were going
he's not poor he's wearing a shirt he's
got he's got a yeah exactly anyway so so
this house absolutely beautiful and
thought I could sell this and then a
thought actually we're renting at twelve
hundred and fifty pound a month so by
various means I got in touch with the
vendor
and just started texting him and I was
like look well loved the house it was
600 the 650-pound a month and it's
really beautiful and he's a bit of works
who you know what's your situation and
it turns out that he's like a data
specialist for the government and he
works in Saudi Arabia so he does like
the infrastructure for data systems
basically top secret and all that he
says so I'm never in the UK he said just
stay there empty and my son comes in
like once a week or whatever he says
what you know doing my head in
and I'm mortgaged up to the hilt with it
so looked in the area and everything's
kind of around to 10 to 20 maybe a push
t30
and he's got it on at 175 so I'm
thinking why why so cheap what's going
on air yeah and he's like I just want to
get rid of it like I'm like I'm
mortgaged up to the eyeballs with it no
one's living there I don't want to pay
the rent on it I just want a way out
so obviously through the training and
and hanging out with you I was like well
you know how about we do this you know
how about you know and I just reeled the
script off the same as in the
documentary the same as you do the crash
course you know I would make you a cash
offer and I think I offered him like 120
or something on a 175 house knowing
you'd say no yeah and then it was gay
stuff okay how about we do this we'll
rent it off yet every month for 650 a
month for the next seven years we have
the option to buy it for 175 thousand
and he's like perfect well I wish I'd
have been offered this a long time ago
so so from that point when I'm looking
at it it's funny in a rented
accommodation that we've been in for a
while we've brought our family up in our
old house and it's just so many amazing
memories my missus was getting to a
point where she couldn't change any
wallpaper or couldn't change any floors
or anything it was you know as you can't
do in rented accommodation and I think
she was getting a bit stir-crazy and
wanted a project
yes to call her yeah yeah so she's so
she's wanted an artistic project I was
looking at it purely property investor
head I could sell this and make two
three thousand quid as a deal because it
works rental wise it yeah I say I say it
works you needed to do a little bit so
it turned it into two parts etc but it
worked as a deal and I was coming at it
from okay so honey only five thousand
will spend twenty three is in fact it
was worth two hundred and five thousand
pounds in 2013
okay so it's so it's already 30 grand
lower than it was in 2000 and 2003 yeah
13 yeah yeah
so when you when if you got the option
to buy it I've got seven years so 2020
Sam option to buy for sorry 175
everything else in the areas 210 220
ballet I'm not being funny but if you
did nothing else yeah you've got your
little bit of income and stuff yeah I
say you stop deal sourcing yeah probably
in seven years you'd be quite a wealthy
man from those two lease options yeah
well we were like knocking for the
kitchen into the diner and open in the
back basically we're modernizing a house
that you get oh yeah good of course of
course good yeah good that's awesome man
okay so get solicitors freddy2 anything
property you know what for sure if
you're getting lease option agreement
yeah because sometimes deals can turn
bad that's just part of it your deal
almost turned bad and you managed to
flip it around by getting a good
management company on but not having a
solicitor not having bright clauses yeah
you know it's really important the way
the way I kind of the way yeah
philosophize about deal sauce in in
there for every dealer sell that's my
solicitors fees for a lease option
agreement yes
so I'm his okay here's the rundown
here's the leak taking right so I'm seen
as many houses as humanly possible and
I'm in a situation now where agents
rather than go let's go to a house and
take the photos and you know put an ad
online and the days it takes to get on
Rightmove then go on a viewing and
someone puts an offer and it falls
through because of a trade rather than
all that they just go Glen we've got a
property you know it the numbers work
ten percent yield 20 whatever percent
ROI trying to come and see it yeah where
is it right here cool that sounds good
let's go meet them there I go I'll sell
that today I'll say that this afternoon
or tonight or tomorrow or whatever right
so yeah it's great because they're
coming to me now going why would we
spend weeks getting a property available
and we can go at this guy and sell it
potentially very quickly well that's
that's the win-win of deal sourcing some
people some people have got money and
they just won't dump it in there people
have got if you're viewing probably is
any way to buy yourself yeah which you
are even if its strategic lease option
agreement cement to rents but if you're
out looking at houses talking to a judge
to flush the deals down the drain
exactly you can't buy yourself when you
could pass them on
yes it's happily gonna die but that's
not but that to me the deal sourcing is
kind of second or third in the league
table because I will always and
consistently and I've even trained a
state agent like I've gone into a state
agency phone if I talked about a lease
option this is what it is so what I want
to do is when I want to take it over a
term of X amount of time with the
options but and I've trained them so
that when they show me a deal they know
they're going to sell it free one of two
ways if I can get it on a lease option
I'll pay the two three grand get it on a
lease option because yeah all right I'm
not technically building a portfolio the
argument is from from the from the
uneducated I suppose is what you don't
own anything and then you like well
Amazon don't own anything air B&B don't
own anything
uber don't own any troll everything oh
nothing Warren Buffett says well there
you go
yeah so so what my first thing is I'll
go in I try get a lease option if I can
get a lease option on it then I will
rent that out knowing that I've really
got myself in with you on the phone just
before the challenge yeah and I remember
you going impossible in yeah Paul yeah
and you saying the wrong with like it's
but now seeing you you've got we got the
one from the week you've now used that
to go get another one which you're
actually living here she's awesome and I
think as well some of the problems you
had with tenants which taught you
because really interesting when you're
making a decision on a day I remember
Grant Cardone signed this chip and I
brought you down to meet Graham yeah and
he said look at the worst case yeah no
yeah if the worst case scenarios gonna
[ __ ] you then don't do it if the
worst case no is gonna be that would be
a bit annoying but I'm gonna be okay but
the best kitchen then you can do it
well actually what he said at the end
was you'll be pissed off you didn't buy
ten of them yes he decides that it's
that so I feel like you know the worst
case with your lease option agreement
that kind of did go bad
to some extent was it's terrible I've
got a three-month break clause I can
walk away no I've lost some money
you don't mean so hey it's okay so I've
got and I've got other ones going
through now as well I hate that but do
you feel though that all that you've
learned from the good from the bad if
you hadn't done that like we could've
gone out for a week and got a couple of
deals I could have almost swimming Wow
you get a man to run them up for every
live happy if happy ever ever that is
not what happened yeah but what has
happened
do you feel like in a way it's giving
you the knowledge and the foundation and
the grounding to now be doing these big
deals and the hotels that's that to me
that last six months was nine months
really no no let's say six months
because it has kind of come out the back
side of it a little bit it's a bit like
a birth squeeze but it was done on such
a grand level with so many people
watching yeah I suppose it's like it's
scary yeah is and there's a lot of
people watching you and a lot of people
judging you whether people say oh I'm
not a judgmental person you absolutely
are you know a lot of these a lot of
these people are and I had but I had to
go through that how do you will come to
my house and it not be filmed yeah and
we did what we did and I carried on I
potentially might be further along but I
would have nowhere near that this
thickness of skin that I have now
honestly because now yeah here's the
thing yeah I get I know when I when I'm
going into a property now I'm not coming
from a place of scarcity which is I
don't know what I'm doing I don't own
any property I I've got no money I'm
scared that's where I was coming from
back then now I'm coming from a place of
even if you even if you took the money
away and took the cut whatever away I
can walk into a property speak with a
vendor and they'll say oh you know well
we're looking to move what we're looking
to do this or we've had it for a while
or someone's died whatever I can look at
that process and go not not how best can
I close them there's a case of what do
they need like and and and I've really
I've become more I've become way more
compassionate like when you were when
you were there my back was up because I
was gay well sorry after when it when
the documented came out my back resort
because I had to protect myself and and
I've learnt now I've learnt now to be
compassionate to be compassionate with
like agents I know everyone's like
agents of the enemy agents are your best
mates and treat them well treat them
well treat vendors well treat your staff
will treat everyone well and somehow
through the magic of the universe it
seems to come back and you just seem to
get more of it so do you feel that
you've become a better person without
question right well that's thanks to you
man I appreciate that you've always been
good person and that's one of the
reasons why yes happy and we and we've
known a good person but we got on like a
house on fire in the week yeah talk to
me about because I want to focus on the
negative
a little bit more no there's not been
enough but talk to me about the auction
property
the infamous stock I'm sorry to bring it
up you did not that was allowed so I'm
asking but listen like if I remember
actually okay you came to some training
I spent about 40 minutes talking about
auction properties yeah
and that if you go to an auction
property always go survey never bite
blind and I think you might have been
video editing probably for me that day
it was the day that the eviction came
out yeah yeah and obviously I was the
died oh no accident wrote it and all I
got it I was I wasn't in the rear coil
it wrote me not being in that room cost
me basically ten thousand cost me nine
thousand three into the vehicle pounds
right it's a mission of so minute part
of the training
yeah so obviously available B's training
but just tell me I think I take check
just tell me because like it's very
powerful story and it's always good if
you're gonna hit the rocks be a
lighthouse yeah ma I really believe that
and you phoned me up and you're like
dude I've just put an offer on a
property at auction I was like oh I mean
you've got to complete right yeah and I
was like ooh and I think Alastair was
like I'll help you with there yeah and
different things but it turned out going
disastrously we're gonna go we were
gonna JV on tell me everything tell what
happened so this property came online
yeah through Northwest auction house I
think he'll called yeah and I thought I
was doing quite well at the time you
know it made some money free source in
and I was like I felt like I was mr.
moneybags yeah at about 12 grand in the
bank
what weird feeling it was yeah it was we
it was like Christmas day every single
moment of my life it was on board the
deal sauce yeah yeah well it was eight
grant from the deals that we've done and
another like 12 grand over it yeah my
lanterns rip that's it that's yeah I
like no one can touch me I just had a
force field around me so yeah I went to
I went to Bolton Wanderers stadium which
about 45 minutes from where I live and
turned up and there was
just hundreds of people there and I
walked in and it said please do not film
anything homes under that yeah home
totally um it there so I'm like great so
see well you know Martin whatever his
face is and all of those like hanging
around so I'm going confident and know
which one I want
there's a property right close to
Stanley Park in Blackpool know Stanley
Park massive plot of land really close
to the hospital really close to the zoo
it's the it's the place to be it's the
prime real estate is the Park Lane and
Mayfair platform yes and off one of the
side streets literally to the point
where I'd say fifty feet you're on
you're literally standing on the park
everything in an area quarter of a
million pound hundred and eighty
thousand three hundred thousand pound
this house 52 grand yeah so I thought I
said a third if not a core richly
honestly is the it's the dream scenario
everyone else in the world is an idiot
because they didn't say that
I must have like the grace of God on my
side was just after maybe the week after
I left your house yeah okay I wasn't
with you at the time this was all my own
doing so head on so sorry sorry it's
faulty that it was forty thousand power
yeah even better right so I get my
paddle yeah and I'm like really I'm like
half nervous cuz I've never done it
before
but I'm also like half like [ __ ] of the
walk because I've just sold some day and
got loads of money in the bank yeah yeah
I know and I must have been I don't
think I'm a very arrogant person but
like in hindsight are probably looking
at myself in a mirror was quite arrogant
at that point because I was like nothing
can touch me yeah so anyway we start
bidding and it goes 46 47 48 and this
too was left 49 50 I go fifty he goes 51
I go fifty two thousand sold 52,000 Nomo
like this was the third this was the
third lot of like a hundred and fifty
lot auctions right yeah so I get push it
off to the side room and I
put down I think it's like 6,000 yeah
maybe maybe a bit more I think it was
maybe no ID but anybody gone wouldn't
the total the total it cost me was 9334
pounds that's including survey scarred
you for life you remember the exact to
the pound yeah yeah actually I think it
might be more that was the total that
was I think the deposit down was was
maybe of seven eight okay anyway
whatever it was what it was a lot of it
was most of my money at the time and I
was out there feeling like an absolute
God and there's a friend of mine Richard
Campbell who was the guy who showed us
the service accommodation long
developments and stuff but mate said I
bought my first house I'm an older I'm a
homeowner I can't believe it and he goes
where is it and I told him and he goes
oh it's not that one second not from the
park is it it's not what you want to
hear yeah he said O God may he said
you're an idiot he said you should have
asked me before you went I was why he
said just go and drive and have a look
at it at this point I'd not even seen it
never I'd look for the legal pack but
nothing else not even not even driven
but what people are gonna say in the
comments who knows well answer them now
is I'm an idiot what were you thinking
like wow i'm a i-i-i-i like hold my
hands up and just accept everything that
is thrown at me about this like I am but
you know I mean do you think it might
have been a combination I don't have
read too much into it between you've got
all this money in the account and you're
like yeah just let me feel rich yeah I
think he might have been and I don't
want it over like spiritualize this or
anything but I believe that we almost
have a money blueprint yeah and we're
almost like like in the same way that
you can have the thermostat set for 20
year I believe personally I have a
millionaire's blueprint yeah I bought it
you could strip me from everything I'd
get it back fast do you feel that maybe
you had a bit of a lower thermostat
setting yeah you just got the money
you just had to sabotage it so I've
never thought about it that way but you
probably right actually I never thought
about it that way so so I went to see it
and honestly you can put a marble at the
front door and it rolled all the way
down to the back door like the
subsidence on it was a joke boat yeah
worse than about worse than about so
about 10-12 years ago there's some
marshland literally my back garden and
one of the big house builders the new
built developers had built four houses
on there every single one of them sank
to the point where you couldn't get in
the front door they had sit there was a
massive court case prison time like it
was it was really variable and that was
my back garden so this house this
subside and son it was terrible so I
paid for a survey 500 quid structural
survey and they said in in our 80 years
doing structural surveys we've never
seen a house with such like brute or not
brutal but you know such such great
subsidence and they said it's remarkable
that's the word they use it's remarkable
that this house is still standing
they said it's due to their cellular
structure of its they basically said
it's relying on next door to stay up and
we don't think this house will be here
it what do they say this sort of like it
would be a miracle if it stayed standing
you find lost unity I pulled out lost my
deposit and actually know what I think
although tenant the tenants of stuff in
HMOs were problems looking back I think
that was that loss of that much money
yeah was the punch in the gut that I was
like you to know I mean it deserved that
post bang yeah you know what that me ask
you something that was a kind of
schoolboy error right there like an
over-enthusiastic yeah
person that just skipped the class yeah
schoolboy error you learned from it and
I'm sure anyone watching this hopefully
will not go and buy an auction property
without viewing it without a survey
after this you are a good communicator
you're a naturally brilliant
communicator one of the things people
picked up from the documentary was that
Wow well this guy is clearly got it yeah
you've got the gift of the gab so just
because some people have said you might
not have any property experience when we
last met but you did have great people
skills good communication might not have
been in business before in this capacity
of in property do you think that and
just be totally honest even if you feel
like it contradicts - yeah but do you
feel that anybody can not not well
because someone choose not to but do you
think anybody can be a deal sauce
be a property or do you think that some
people are just knockout for it
unfortunately I think the second I think
I think I've I've had a lot of self
analysis over this last nine months good
and bad a very honest look in the mirror
of yeah you good at this but also you
could be a bit you know whatever yeah
and I always knew prior to meeting you
prior to proper even being a thing that
I was I was gonna be successful at
something yeah I just didn't know what
yeah I had the fire there yeah I had
success with YouTube and I had success
we've offered jobs and stuff I'd had but
I property was one of those things that
I'll build my wealth in property but
I'll make the income from something else
yeah but property long-term property
investment is where I will make I will
become a rich man 3 3 that my blueprint
you say about blueprint my blueprint was
not necessarily to the extent I know I
know
trainers and stuff use this as an
extreme of rich people a greedy and
money's the root of all leave and that
kind of stuff yeah that my blueprint
wasn't there yeah but I definitely had
some very deeply ingrained relationships
with money that I needed to you you lit
the fire so you came and said here's how
you do this thing here's how you deal
sauce and and what wasn't on the
documentary is we spent a lot of time
driving a lot of time talking a lot of
time you saying you know rather than say
this kind of phrase which is disabling
use this phrase which is enabling you
know you gave me a lot of training in
that regard and for quite a quite a
short period of time I was battling
myself between well here's this thing
that works deal sourcing works and a lot
of people want to get to know your deals
enough let you know we we proven that
Blackpool is a really good place to
invest but you're still you're still
sabotaging yourself you're still
dragging yourself down you're still
finding ways to to crucify yourself yeah
for for these reasons that you know your
that is your thermostat and I think
eventually after you know it's like the
fight of good versus evil and God versus
the devil like you get to a point where
if you
do something long enough the the thing
that you focus on more becomes bigger
and expands and becomes greater and the
thing that you didn't want that you're
not giving any focus and attention to
shrinks into nothingness and and that's
where I feel like that's why my
blueprint was like I still battle
everyday with things that I want to
better about myself things that I want
to improve but in terms of can anyone do
this like I I don't think so unless
unless you can unless you can so
brutally honest in fact dr. dr. Joe
Dispenza he's incredible man and he says
that you can heal anything in your body
he says but you've got kill yourself
first yeah
because your matter trying to change
matter and when you can become energy
trying to change matter then you can
change everything I started meditating I
started I started meditating going to
Reiki working a lot on my spiritual yeah
you know because of a lot of the stuff
that was going on online and trying to
hell myself at the same time that
process have been quiet for an hour and
I'm good that I've only discovered it in
my 30s yeah has changed everything
because that shatter that thing that
says you're not good enough you can't do
this you're never going to make money
who do you think you are all these
people are saying this thing about you
maybe they're right yeah scene is that
sure but soon as that chatter quietens
down yeah and you can just be at peace
with yourself you're like actually I'm
offering a good service and I'm offering
value to people yeah and they're getting
great things from it they're they're
buying investments that they're gonna
pass through their generations possibly
their family for generations and it's
gonna make cash flow and and you're it's
almost a gift you know to them that they
can have four four generation businesses
win-win so it goes is you give value and
then money will follow yeah you know but
it's really interesting what you're
saying dude if you can check if you can
change that inner monologue if you if
you can because all I can really do is
teach people the strategies yeah I try
and give you know motivate people but
ultimately I can give people all of the
tools yeah they've gotta be right in
here yeah with with I mean I don't know
major amounts about your background but
I mean to get to where you got to at
such a young age is credit to you you've
never really had to quo
quote struggle financially is that fair
is that fair to say okay well I will I
apologize if you have strewed compared
to compared to some to some everything's
relative
but yeah of course I think when you've
been running that program for such a
long period of time
one thing that is massively valuable is
being honest with yourself yeah and I
wasn't when you came to me I was not
honest with myself about III boxed a lot
of things out I pushed a lot of things
that I didn't want to admit about myself
do you think we could have done with
having a month a month together yeah
maybe maybe so I think you do it like we
I think could have been a psychological
mess right out point I think the reason
yeah the reason that the reason I say
that is there's there's a point in the
documentary where we were at my kitchen
table actually and I was saying to you
this is huge this mental block
I remember the the messages afterwards a
huge amount of messages were by a
brilliant I've really enjoyed it
you would not believe how much I
resonated with that with what you were
saying about fear that thing holding you
back yeah and and the reason that I say
like your your situation yeah the way
you've been financially or whatever I
think when you're like trying to raise
kids and and you know you go for a bit
of a midlife crisis and you're like I'm
skinned what am I gonna do and I think a
lot of people you can look honestly it
yourself
yeah have that kind of mentality they
see your training and go but this is a
way out like this is this is this is
something that I could really do you
know and it's inspiring seeing these
people
yeah it's inspiring seeing these people
have such amazing success the first step
towards getting that is is to have a
very distinct almost like MOT of your
mind
yeah of going what do I really think
about money what do I really think about
success
am I really willing to put in the hours
and hours and hours and hours to do this
because if you don't you'll quit yeah
and loads of people do that like you
know I think yeah I think you're right
and I think and one of the things I
loved about the week and I said this too
at the time was seeing it like seeing
the fear and seeing that yeah sort of
some of the mental challenges and
battles I don't usually see that I and
we spoke about this and it was in the
one of the things that shocked me okay
is is really when we did the eviction
yeah okay because you film the eviction
and directed it and added some you will
leave Samuel yeah and and and and you
know that was no sometimes people that
some people said oh you know you knew
each other already but we have very
upfront about the fact yeah you know we
knew each other before I said but I
still have no property experience yes
exactly so so here's the funny thing I
so I got diagnosed with this tumor
in the December yeah we started talking
aren't just after Christmas yeah by
January it was let's do it like let's
let's create the TV addiction the
eviction I'm okay just point out for
everyone watching I came up with the
name of victory and you said he wants to
be a property millionaire that was you
that was the way that I wrote that the
way that I wrote that that series was
based entirely off watching your YouTube
videos and going this is the same thing
keeps coming up here so what about deal
sourcing what about refurbs well and
that would that created the episodes yes
now I've got you excited yeah that was
there was one moment where there was
Hannah Anthony Ricki and John Rae bolt
who by the way John Rae bolt and Anthony
have been angels to me recently like
what a bunch of great guys
those guys secured I think was three
hundred thousand pounds worth of
property on a lease option agreement in
Derby they started with nothing so I'm
in the car with them we're driving an
ALICE that me and Alice they're driving
him around they and they got nothing and
at that point I realized that it was
possible what they were doing so I was
like rather than be behind the camera
like I need to I need to start doing
this property stuff myself so I started
looking at properties never really found
anything and then you release that thing
so yeah I'm gonna go to someone's house
and I'm like that's gotta be me like
whatever happens because I was coming
from a place of scarcity obviously
because I'm a health but at the same
time I realize in such close proximity
to people who all of them really apart
from maybe nc' and maybe Kirstie yes I
think that's it they were all younger
than me yeah you're younger than me so
I'm like I just haven't had the exposure
to this world and then suddenly these
people are getting uh we started with no
money in two days we got $300 you saw
those firsthand and Yemen and I remember
you met I remember you calling me up and
uh speaking you say dude I've just seen
the video
yeah and always they come to the class
yeah yeah you did yeah you kept all
right you didn't ignore me but I was
like dude let it be me let it be mean
you're like no come to the cross you
know you kept coming to us and you came
in and asked it was a fabulous moment
but when we did the eviction and I by
the way I have like so much love for you
as a person you know and I'm so glad
that we went through the week the week
that we did but here's the thing was
that when we did the eviction yeah there
was Hannah and I was Antony yeah and
they were both wanted 20 grams yeah and
I said I didn't want to give it to
hammer because putting 20 grand in to
rent to serviced accommodations was too
risky whereas Anthony was putting it
into a safe property yeah
now after the challenge that we did I
said to you I was prepared to give you a
20,000 pound loan to buy a property yeah
and you were like and then you pitched
the idea
another thing we spoke about this it's
you were like how about instead I'll put
it into rent serviced accommodations to
remember that yeah and I was like he's a
bit risky like why did you not want to
put into a house and also just with your
money in general a because like what's
what's you know what okay no most people
the question going back when you'd
finish the challenge and you had all
this money from deal source and yeah
yeah access I offered to give you 20
grands alone obviously obviously when
you present offered to give it because
you said you was put into rent to rent
yeah I thought was risky yeah going back
with that money and the access to funds
would you do anything different and if
so what would it be
are you saying he's saying if I was to
take if if some1 gay that's 20 grand now
I don't even 20 like you've made fifty
plus thousand pound deal sorcerer yeah
you had the 12 grand you know like go
back as an investor yeah what would you
do with the home I am I am still I'm
from Blackpool so I'm still a bit of a
skinflint like Eddie I mean we're in
London now paying four quid for a pint
pisses me off like I still like to look
after my money
yeah
even though I spend ten of it on stupid
auction houses given that money
I still want Lease Option agreements the
reason why I want lease option agreement
is because the money to get into the
lease option agreement and do it up and
refurb it so you know whatever extent
you're gonna do he's still going to make
money back on that yeah because usually
these okay obviously the first deal that
the HMO lease option to one side usually
they're either T flats or a house or
like whatever is them the more the most
simple deals yeah so that over a
seven-year span and I literally go for
seven years every single time because
like fives a bit too short for the
markets move I feel that tends too much
of a commitment I might be wrong about
that but seven was right yeah seven
works with me so I would in my mind it's
roughly two to sue in half grand to get
into a lease option to get all your
solicitors to do all all of that kind of
stuff it's about two to two an Afghan so
if someone gave me twenty grand today I
will try and get ten Lease Option
agreements because ten Lease Option
agreements at two three four five
hundred-pound profit ammonia is gonna be
two three four five thousand pound a
month almost completely passively
assuming that you then pay ten fifteen
percent for a manager also there's the
potential that is going to go up in
capital gains so in seven years let's
say let's say abort ten have the lease
option agreement on ten houses you know
a hundred grand H there's the potential
that if those hundred grands turn into
130 or 140 yeah you know you you sat on
thirty forty well three hundred four
hundred thousand yeah and that's fair I
am what are you favorite deals to source
for you investors so if somebody comes
to us as I've got fifty been an investor
yes you're not gonna go find them a
whole bunch at least option of what what
kind of properties are the best
properties last seeing or let's change
it flats okay tell me why because
they're priced the purchase price of
them is based very similar to a normal
standard dwelling but you're getting
double the rent on it so you've got two
houses next to each other ones a normal
by to that ones to farts yeah the bottle
that is a hundred grand
yeah the two flats are a hundred twenty
grand yeah the bottle that will get you
five maybe six hundred a month the flats
are doing four hundred and fifty a month
each yeah so that's bringing you nine
hundred 120 outlay and this one's
bringing you six
400 outlays just there is a better
economy of money straightforward yeah
cash on cash and also we I mean
specifically with regards to source in
the it's very attractive to a an
investor yeah if you say to them all the
bills are covered the council tax is
covered yeah you know utilities are
covered yeah they want broadband
discovered you put the money in there's
no other cost apart from obviously
insure and buildings insurance and stuff
like that but there's there's hardly any
outlay
yeah and it's good and it's good link as
well for people to contact you about
that yeah absolutely last question I
just just want to clarify my first ever
business right this is how this how
green hours so so straight after you
went home I was like going to get into
this sourcing yeah and I called my
company awesomesauce yeah and I didn't
actually realize that awesomesauce
in America is slang for male ejaculate
oh wow so as to change that yeah grab
that really really quickly I change what
you like okay last question last
question brilliant so if we were to sit
on this over again and meet up yeah
three years time yeah which I'm sure we
will do we may do you I'm shaking back
on the channel but if we were to meet
back to three years time what do you
expect or what are your aspirations what
do you expect life to look like property
wise in just generally three years time
fantastic question I have the freedom to
go wherever I want do whatever I want
with my family my friends and basically
money for forever has always been an
object so it's been a problem it's never
been looked at positively now because of
my change in mentality and who I think I
am as a person I'm not a religious man
but I I don't feel that there's any
limit to me not only financially not
only business I just don't feel like I
have any you know the sunroofs opened on
me now
so with regards that question there is
there is no limit like I have no doubt
maybe not in three years but certainly
within five years my portfolio will be
way in excess of a million pounds way in
excess because I now I'm taking that
money from you go understand coming from
a standing start yeah it I can't just go
out and go
I love that hundred thousand pound house
and I love that 150 thousand pound house
and I won that one I know like cuz you
don't the money to do it so I've spent
the last nine months building that part
up building that money up and it and
just rinsing and repeating it yeah
through the lease options that I've got
going on through the properties that I'm
purchasing at the moment and and I'm
making more money which means I'm
investing more money which means it's
compound interest so I'm at a point I
mean I'm obviously nowhere near your
level but I'm at a stage where I feel
great because I've got some security now
yeah I feel great because I'm helping
people everyday through my deal source
in course and all that kind of stuff
have a good can contribute in I feel
good that I sleep well at night knowing
that I'm helping people I don't I don't
feel stressed and and ultimately if you
if if I like forget three years let's
talk six months it was six months I can
it like this tumor is gone because I'm
not stressed yeah that's my goal like it
is to be you know you use my body in my
mind to be the best servant that I can
while I'm while I'm here on this planet
and not you know not just hoard all to
myself start giving it out and teaching
other people to do the same and just
liberate I suppose a similar journey to
yours really just making the world a
better place a better place than when
you came here you know yeah I love that
but I love your heart and your desire to
inspire people which is what we did do
mmm to do the documentary also as well
fonder words I want to say thank you for
letting me come and live with you for a
week yeah and for me it was you were a
bit like a guinea pig in a way it's a
social experiment for me so seeing how
it's panned out it's just really think
it's you know it's it's it's a really
amazing story we'll go down in history
it's changed my life like he's such a
throw away phrase genuinely like my my
life is not the same as it was yeah nine
months ago yeah I'm a different person
inside outside financially spiritually
energetically and and that's because you
took the time to come and to come and do
that you know it's funny I get people
messaging me now saying would you be
willing to do what Samuel did for you do
it I know you but originally I was going
Alex obviously when I challenge you to
do
and then let's have a rippling of yeah
cause the world see if ya absolutely
respect man
Thank You min thank you for your time
appreciate it
[Music]
the future is now